[Musique]
son incompréhension de voir un proche
se laisser aller comme ça se laisser
violenter se laisser diminuer se laisser
perdre là-dedans
[Musique]
souvenez-vous de ce témoignage
crève-cœur celui de Sylvain duguide dont
la mère a perdu 70 000 $ au moins de
fraudeur des spécialistes de l'arnaque
amoureuse et bien dans ce dossier là
aussi il y a du nouveau d'abord un
rappel de l'affaire comment il y a
charme il lui disait je pense des mots
que peut-être que ma mère jamais attendu
d'un homme probablement c'est peut-être
ce qu'il a qui venait la chercher
qu'elle aimait entendre
[Musique]
ma mère a donné ses NIP de tout a donné
il y avait accès à tout tout
Sylvain fait une découverte dans les
documents de sa mère une note manuscrite
avec un nom qui lui dit rien espoir
Croatie
plus tard la SQ va découvrir que ce même
espoir Croatie a fait près de 40
victimes partout Québec
des hommes et des femmes qui dans
certains cas ont perdu toutes les
économies d'une vie la fraude à l'église
s'élève à plus de 2 millions de dollars
c'est en moyenne 50 000 dollars par
victime
bonjour monsieur Coincy bonjour je
m'appelle Marie mauve Denis je suis
journaliste à la télévision de
Radio-Canada et j'aimerais vous parler
du dossier de fraude d'arnaque à l'amour
pourquoi
vous voulez pas discuter
ont finalement plaidé coupable récemment
à Québec Landry and show a été condamné
à 6 mois moins un jour de prison
pourquoi 6 mois moins un jour parce que
ultimement ça pourrait lui éviter d'être
expulsé du Canada quant à sa co-accuser
Christelle saumon elle a bénéficié d'une
absolution conditionnelle mais la tête
dirigeante de ce réseau au Québec espoir
Croatie risque beaucoup plus la
poursuite réclame une peine de 350
prisons mais aussi le remboursement des
victimes et une amende pour un total de
800 mille dollars et quoi qu'il en soit
au terme de sa peine il sera déporté
vers la Côte d'Ivoire
j'espère que vous avez apprécié les
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre langue
[Musique]